and everybody welcome to stream Coco
yeah my party shirt on now quick story
before we get started our head
accounting lady and next woman my name
is sue lane so we work in the Warner
Brothers lot Ellen the TV show and the
person DeGeneres also is on the Warner
Brothers lot and every year she has a
clothing sale right this is a true thing
where she sells her clothing the
clothing of her DJ and who else like in
turns clothes or something I don't know
whatever guest clothes yes guest goes so
sue Lane
god bless her heart goes to the Ellen
sale sees this shirt and just buys it
for me and it's just like hey I got you
this shirt she [ __ ] nailed it man
look at this this is great you the whole
back is listen you know I don't want to
show too much of the behind this isn't
an nc-17 ready to thank you that's great
it's five bucks amazing and the reason
why I'm wearing this shirt is because
today we're playing a game that's very
intense it is a game probably my
favorite game of the last four years
it's called hell-blade since suit sense
anyways I don't know how to say it
send usual sensuous anyways sacrifice
it's a terrible name hell played guys
the name you messed up that you messed
up the name but it's a great game it's
amazing and the whole thing is now
here's the thing if Beth doesn't know
this but we're gonna be playing with
headphones today now the idea is that
seonhwa we're just gonna call are sent
away I think your name is Senne oh hey
what's up oh thanks Mary otter this
shirt is incredible by the way it feels
incredible you gonna feel it just
kidding just a normal shirt I spent
about to touch me you fell into my trap
go right in so uh yes so the game is you
are basically a woman and I'm not gonna
ruin anything but you're a woman in
Viking times and you have a mental
illness you hear voices you have
psychosis and this game is of not a
funny game it treats it very seriously
but it treats mental illness the way
I've never seen in a game before so you
hear all these voices all over like
while you're doing [ __ ] like while
you're doing anything
you're hear voices so if you have
headphones please put them on and if
you're watching with other people you
didn't want to hear my voice you should
be wearing headphones anyway don't be a
dick about it
hey jungle Germania what's up hey nice
bikes hey Dylan so this game is super
creepy and super awesome and you hear a
lot of voices and we're gonna play and
I'm gonna make Beth where some goddamn
headphone all right let's do it ready
okay we're gonna look stupid but you
know I've already not in this shirt all
right here we go oh yeah now it might be
too loud is it too loud I can hear you
but we might be screwed all right I'm
gonna turn it down all of it on here is
Trent is this even working okay how's
this is this good for you yeah this is
scaring the [ __ ] on you scares the [ __ ]
out of me all right here we go guys they
get the character mariotta I yeah I
guess his schizophrenic yeah but she
hears voices and also I'm not gonna talk
a lot in the beginning because it's very
immersive and cool and if we could shut
off the lights I would Stephanie yes I
love you too Owen did you want to shop
the lights because we dim them we could
dim them let's dim the well of it guys
were getting into hell-blade also I
gotta say this I would just buy this
game it's so good
I played the entire thing over the
weekend by the way I played for like 20
hours over the weekend like 10 hours
Saturday 10 hours Sunday and then like
when I was done I kind of googled it and
it was like oh you could finish the game
is 6 hours and I was like oh I suck
I played 420 all right here we go it's
getting intense
how great is this of cinema oh yeah guys
this game is intense man the head on our
blood is breathing is this great yeah
that's true
oh my heavy breathing adds to the effect
I never told you of the others oh yeah I
love it when they put the credit title
isn't it that's not helpful yet I think
just came out I think the darkness
changed them just like it changed
I'm nervous man I'm already nervous
it is real laughter we got some dead
bodies there oh how was it that treats
Chuck yeah the tree cakes there it is
whoo
Beth by the way can I just say I was
totally freaked out about this game the
voices Beth is like totally fine with it
I just like we jumped through hoops to
hook up headphones if that doesn't care
at all she's just like
they lie voting at the fields and rivers
of hell
but that don't always lie still here
do that to you can you see them can you
see them you guys do that to you
all right we're back thanks gamer wolf
the thing is I don't get scared by jump
scares I get scared by like creepy [ __ ]
like this this is horrifying this in
like my shirt or the scariest thing is
going on right now that's a bad way to
die man
gimme a stick right up your bum that way
to die I love like this like all this
design is so cool is this great and this
this game is seriously a movie looks
like it would be good in like VR yeah it
would be awesome in VR I'll let may be a
little too intense and parts we should
make a close game room or wind I gotta
play more away imagine how bad this
would smell by the way you don't even
swimming in this all these dead bodies
it's like the East River in New York
Sammy says her be creeped out by Conan
ah no although he did call me into his
office yesterday and he was laying like
taking a nap he's like sit down he's
like he was doing a bit where he was
like being a dead zombie it's - he does
frighten us when he kicks like kicks in
the door yeah it's a little creepy
that's far deeper
I'm gonna try to not talk as much in the
in the stream because this is a creepy
game and I want I want to make sure
people experience it the right way yeah
if you guys have questions we'll answer
them
right okay so if you have questions
we'll answer them but I'm not just gonna
all talk willy-nilly cast iron wok makes
a good point
all right here we go all right let's get
into it
oh I'm so scared
it's not too late to get into the boat
and go back no one will judge no one
will ever know oh there's no going back
pushes away a world that conspired to
cause so much suffering there's nothing
to go back to and worse to look forward
to
why don't you join us
maybe you too have a part to play in
this story is this great also do you
guys want the subtitles on or not that's
another question I'll ask you guys
alright because your darkness coming
from hell and your fate lies there
they say the burning of a but gods and
the living
you must leave the Isles of Orkney
across the eastern sea and find a road
that leads north and down through deep
dark valleys after nine nights of riding
you will follow a great river and will
find a bridge covered in gold the path
to Helheim goes from there across the
river of knives the flows from the dark
world of nifflheim
yeah
Congress
she's not stopping
dude how scary is this game
what he said
the river of knives across which lies
the halls of hell
the place they call home hi-yah
there's no doubt about the goddess hello
but I beloved
Bridget a health home
today she forgets to but she does
remember I don't need a dead cross
let's see shall we
yes the same as the Avengers hella it's
the K planchette
why did you do that I love this with
these voices it's so crazy also if
you're listening ahead but they're like
all around you it's super creepy
[Music]
[Laughter]
so creepy like me
hashtag drift truth
yelling friend don't be coughing in my
ear the old friend
I don't know captive quasar I'm not sure
the voices get it I mean so basically we
have to find and that's a part of this
game you played the witness there's a
lot of like puzzles of like looking for
[ __ ] in plain sight and that's true in
this game too so we need to go find
where the rune exists but the cool thing
about this game is that's something that
that also like people get obsessed with
sometimes like people mental health
issues to see things in the world so the
question is like do these runes really
exist or is this all in her mind because
she just pushed open the door herself
like that's the thing you're battling in
this game is like how much is reality
and how much is like just all in your
head it's awesome
I could you could you've just pushed
open the door
you listen on everyone else left now we
got another voice
Giroud the Northland thing are pure
eight truth Oh God
what's up Nick Mack you guys are just
joining us we're playing hell blade sent
to a sacrifice I love this game it's
about a woman in north's time so as
mental illness it's really great and
she's basically we're trying to get to
hell to save the soul of her former
lover and there's it's beautiful I heard
that this is an indie game which seems
insane god I gotta concentrate I'm
really bad at balancing stuff in video
games told you told you I'm terrible at
this
ah come on I could get over there there
we go all right we did it the world is
ruled by the giant our fathers so as a
child the old father cast her down into
Helheim and gave her power over those
who possess age hardship that's self
slaughter in all of the nine worlds only
Helen can resurrect the dead hello -
hello
your Dillion was sacrificed yeah
terrific Heights given me major anxiety
- actually I get more claustrophobic
more of a claustrophobic fella who
should we go down here or should we go
this way oh you know what I think we
have to go down there yeah oh no wait I
can do it there's the road over the
river of knives if I ever buy a house
I'm definitely putting a river of knives
around it so people can't get in that's
my you know instead of like why spend
your money on a big alarm system just
put a river of knives out there man
you know the robbers would be like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] don't even come near yet
they want to be get close enough to like
break a window cuz you got a river of
knives around your house you know hey
big puana tiger green she did dry off
really fast you know the air is pretty
dry here I'm making that up okay here we
go
shits about to get gnarly guys
the gate to hell if so it's a terrible
rendering a wayward mole says if I buy a
house
hello we'll move in with me I think my
apartments haunted anyway right now oh
yeah hey I got a ghost which is why I
like this game so much oh oh I hear
voices I hear voices dude [ __ ] here
comes the darkness yo
now we're in it dude
go Bosch I don't know is this great does
this look insane
[Applause]
yeah it's on baby
hard to kill a shadow beast dude doesn't
really seem fair I can't hit him what's
up dude not cool not cool how am I
supposed to fight these shadow dudes I
think they're kind of cheating dude why
is it all dark game's rigged
it seems extremely not cool lame-o oh oh
we die
like this
a vision
does not reason it is robbed and now it
has taken hold it will spread towards
her head the right dude seat of the soul
maybe it's just excellent so check this
out this is the other part about this
game every time you die the rock grows
on your arm and if it reaches your head
you're dead forever the game is over you
have to start over isn't that stressful
it's crazy stressful so there's like
perma death in this game like Dark Souls
isn't that awesome
so good so good this game is so
stressful and it's it's what it's like
living with eczema it's a terrible
disease eczema is a terrible disease
that's some [ __ ] up excellent
for now because she still has control of
her mind now or like every Nintendo game
yes you can do it man
to be fair I also carry the rat around
the head of my ex-girlfriend so it's a
normal thing
Sam D I don't know how many times I
don't know how many times now look I
I respect the got a fire but cert is a
dumb name cess you RT lame as hell man
alright guys should we go uh should we
go illusion or fire illusion or fire
chat should we go I'm gonna do like this
this is my symbol for illusion and this
is my symbol for fire fire fire illusion
fire clearly clubber lang we're playing
hell-blade this game is awesome need
there turn around I can't dude illusion
sounds crazy what do you think is it
more fire more illusions I say we do
fire I think it's more action-oriented
yeah fire light it up we're doing it I
think you guys want to see action right
so this is the more action-oriented one
she should go out with Jorah Marmont
he'll rot meat greyscale let's do oh
yeah boy he comes from
[Music]
kind let's do it you gotta get that
cough looked at dearth truth yeah truth
you got to get like some nyquil or
something bro
whatever you take for you buy yeah how
beautiful is this game by the way it's
gorgeous yeah this is gonna be lit here
we go we got the New York Yankees runes
over here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's on bring
it boy yeah I'll try dude
oh by the way the voices when you're
playing on headphones are crazy miss me
oh right in the back
you know they say don't stab a guy in
the back but that's the best time to
stab them because he's back astern you
can't hit you oh [ __ ] I will say I think
these guys wearing skulls
over their faces is not great for their
battle prowess they're at a bit of a
disadvantage you know oh yeah double
make cry this is by the guys who made
Devil May Cry ooh speaking of burning
human flesh I went to this restaurant
last night called animal and had a bone
marrow burger I was so good I didn't ask
what kind of bone marrow it was but it
was delicious
so where we going here front step yes
this is ninja Theory again we're playing
hell blade worst name for a game but
awesome game I love this game again like
it's all I did this weekend was play
this game I didn't ask what kind of bone
marrow you know I just trusted they
would give me something legal tell the
way cry was do where's this other one am
I looking at here
you know anybody seen any wise anywhere
I mean there's what all kinds of wise
are in here oh here we go
that guy's having a bad day right there
all right shits open let's do it yeah
all right
you know what that's what I put on my
bum bow profile
I already walk among the dead no matches
by the way so there you go
maybe I should change this just like
read by nature says this is just Burning
Man basically this is the worst
Coachella I've ever been to
I love this though so I think we're
trying to get up there said weird
mountain hedgehog
that's where hell is there we go
alright now this part gets a little
gnarly I'm not gonna lie I mean there's
already like it's not gonna catch me
sleeping baby wait wait like where's
some armor yeah that's true you know I
do love me my mortal kombat references
woo woo sup baby what do you got oh
don't think so
Oh dick oh yeah that's really Oh
two on one huh oh I got a little spinny
action
yeah whatever you got something on your
face oh it's my sword [ __ ] what's up
now
Oh stabby stabby you know I love the
stabs there's not too many of them come
on easy
don't [ __ ] with a lady don't stand
between a lady and her former lovers
soul yeah you don't I'm saying you see
me coming I got my boyfriend's head in a
bag why would you even step to this all
right here we go
fire gate of cert sorry cert maybe
because it sounds like I do love certain
Tyler I love certs mattresses yeah sir
start out as a fiery God and then got
out of the fire-god business and went to
the mattress business it's very
lucrative it's very lucrative all right
all right this is gonna be gross take
the kids out of the room and by the way
the kid kids shouldn't be watching this
stream anyway ooh what's this a bunch of
dead burning bodies cool that's gross
this is gonna be I will say though not
for nothing I bet just charred human
flesh
you know smells like hamburgers right or
something
[Music]
oh boy yeah now my clothes are gonna
smell like smoke like I've been to the
bar Oh God
I will say drouth is dressed like a
Norseman of the times or like a Silver
Lake hipster yes you know what's like
that hat with a little like deer skull
in it that could easily be at home it's
over like yeah cert is waiting for me I
got a thing or two to say about cert
this story before the earth was created
there was a muscle right muscle burning
it was down in Florida orcs that flew
out the muscle became the stars others
Faro's melted ice in the frozen world of
nifflheim creating the body of the first
giant Amir yeah is one of the nine
worlds and is neither land upon fire
Giants who from elsewhere cannot endure
a journey there
cool so I'll put a travel advisory
advisor on Muspel to not go there
got it thanks drew a priest bro I
appreciate it
where am i effing going here this way I
will say one thing that the north's
men are really good at is making fences
ladies that's a great fist
I'd rather have this on my property than
like chain-link fence so when I buy a
house I'm going river of knives and then
I think that's kind of like spear
fencing yeah it'll be a great house -
Trick or Treat - you know I don't ya can
go can I go here yet I gotta do
something else oh you know what I got to
go across the thing down here I think
mahdev seven yes this is a great again
we're playing hell-blade this game is
amazing super fun super interesting
really creepy it gets super super
intense I loved it and I can't believe
it's like an indie game I mean it's it's
truly incredible I can't recommend it
enough this is my favorite game since
inside which was another amazing game we
played Susskind Park here comes with bad
guys oh yeah that's right
I will say like the voices in your head
also really help you because it's like
they're telling us like remember the way
back like you're gonna everything's
gonna be on fire don't be a dumbass it's
like having a lot of jiminy crickets in
your head sexy jiminy crickets
that's what they should have named this
game sexy jo7 sexy jiminy crickets rolls
off the tongue ahh
ash like I love this game sorry I just
can't take cert seriously oh look at
this dude oh dude oh man all right let's
do it ready as soon as we touch it it's
just gonna go bananas all right let's go
ah
Jesus
Oh
whoo answer your prayer singer I ask the
gods for mercy all of them even there's
none in the end I set myself free
find your own like I find mine yeah just
like Conan not coming to this stream
I've got to abandon the fire-god
air-quality poor this is just like Los
Angeles by the way little smoggy today
on the 405 all right here we go
Thank You toku it's nice to me to say
now listen I have oh we got to go do the
room thing god damn it yeah and you if
you get this game or should I say when
you get this game cuz everybody should
buy it you got to play with headphones
that's the whole thing
that's why that's what makes this game
great where are the rooms are something
I'm supposed to do oh here we go what it
is
all right here we go also I will say I
have played this game I kind of know
what to do from arrant there we go I had
it done uh like ghosting a girl he
ghosted a lot of girls Yanks
so this game would make a great rom-com
I think where is that it's like here or
something what am i doing it does kind
of help you I don't I would be
completely lost without like this it's
like here right or something oh here we
go
we're so close alright it's something
with these trees right something no
goddamnit
I have even started packing for Tel Aviv
I think it's like this is this not gonna
work send out work come on give it to me
come on oh you know what it's right here
I bet there it is there it is
just a little tweak
yeah this gamma took took a lot from
Batman what are you talking about our
parents were killed in an alley by a Joe
Chill oh man
no wait where's the thing I gotta go
look at the thing does it just straight
ahead okay got to pay attention man I
don't know it's worse when the voices
are talking to you or when they're quiet
you know mm-hmm all right here we go
let's do it fire time let's go
we're already on flair god dammit let's
go run dude run [ __ ] we can't go this
way
oh that's dude oh Jesus can't go that
way
[ __ ] I don't remember this part all
right there we go
Oh can't go that way
[ __ ] come on dude run what are you doing
let's go oh I'm terrible with this I'm
terrible at this I'm terrible at this
you guys know I'm terrible at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] terrible
this let's go
it's like God man we're going here we go
oh come on dude what not cool I don't
know my ain't nobody got time for this
Jaime
all right can we please stop fighting
guys so we're don't burn up
oh my god dude that was
I see nothing Lebowski nothing I will
say how great would it be just imagine
for a moment if Danny McBride was Drew
yo it kind of looks like Danny McBride
this is gnarly I think looks very Danny
McBride ask did you see his Danny
McBride's Instagram about the oh that's
where the bad guy is the Instagram about
late the Eclipse it 16 your lane moon
I'll popping off like you're the Sun hey
you know what I have to do I think I
have to go oh look at all these bodies
dude
gnarly this is very stressful this game
we are definitely gonna watch the Conor
McGregor fight go Conor man I'm 100%
team Connor we didn't close gamer with
him and he was the nicest dude ever so
cool genuine funny a great guy
what am i doing you don't Rob here oh
wait maybe do
I will say I do wish she ran a little
faster but it kind of adds to like the
creepiness of the game that you can't go
that fast I mean this game is all about
the story cert cert
you ever really helped me so far dude no
offense truth oh wait there we go we got
this one here boom sauce right little
boom sauce I think we got it come on
that's another it is P can I good up P
what's the last we have to get it's like
a weird X thing get food down here so I
agree Steve cert is the worst name
oh no wait we came up this way idiot
perma death is in real life so stop
putting it in games somebody said that's
true it doesn't make it super stressful
though because there is that thing in
like and fallout 4 if you want to do
some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] or like Grand
Theft Auto you just go insane and you
kill a bunch of people and then it kind
of doesn't matter and it does kind of
take away from the game I will say it's
not super amazing where's the last thing
is it up here
SIRT I mean all these characters look I
don't mean to [ __ ] on cert as a name
because it's like a old norse name and
like a it's like they didn't make it up
the hell-blade guys ninja theory didn't
make up cert but it is kind of funny
come on
maybe the Norse Norse people just really
loved their sleep or is it oh here we go
Oh what I got to get on the other side
of this right how do we do that here I
see you we're gonna see if we can get to
the head guy we got five more minutes
we're gonna see if we could kill cert
and his dumb name in this dream I think
we can we're almost there
Oh cert I'm coming for you baby
see you Mary honor thanks for joining us
you're a camp counselor the girl with
hair like that you mean dreads
let's do
here we go oh I'm gonna survive the fire
sir let's do this I'm ready me and my
dumb shirt all right let's go yeah I'm
trying bro let's go run did
I'm on fire I was a fake-out we're still
on fire here we go
how intense is this game
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry
the darkness takes everything
I feel
fight this together my sign
that's Dillion was my battle I have to
face it alone away from here
I don't know
I believe in you
you know that
just
just promise me
and you will come back to me
I want you to say
I want you to say
I will come back to you I promise
oh yeah
you destroyed everything everyone but by
kit now let's go sir you got a dumb name
oh [ __ ]
yeah let's get him
we're using our focus shield power
let's go sir Oh
[Music]
yes
for every party one the greater battle
takes its place but sort goals
until we fall
Danny refried we all fall
the gods have their time
yet we still go on
and I won't go to hell I die
free
you will carry my stories
my question
in this life and the next
to fulfill yours
I was
be ready
to face heart in the eye
as I have to find your answers request
you know truth you could have just said
good job you know I don't need all the
drama man you can just be like great job
you killed sir you had a dumb name a
cage with a face full of fire good job
you know that's all it takes all I ask
just a little support you know drew uh
guys
that's gonna do it for us today I think
we proved our point to cert that his
name was stupid and we defeated him in
single combat this game is awesome it's
called hell blade sent to his sacrifice
I can't recommend it enough I love this
game but definitely plan on headphones
it's super fun very very intense it's
gorgeous and creepy and awesome and
thank you for joining us that will do it
for today scream Co Co guys no screw
coco next week we're going to be
overseas and Israel so I'll be in Israel
actually so make sure to follow us on
Instagram snapchat Facebook what else
both both Twitter's Conan O'Brien at
Team Coco because we will be live
streaming and videoing and snapping and
tweeting and saying hey from Israel
that's right so we're super excited we
can't wait and thank you all for joining
us and we'll see you guys next week from
Israel and then maybe the following week
here we'll see thanks thank you - ninja
3 who made a great help late game thanks
to Jason Cooper at the corner Bethan
röszke have a great Wednesday see you
guys later
you